I need people way ahead of me in life
that as good as I'm doing these guys are
going to make me feel small there's a
there's a power to having people around
you that make you feel like relax bro
you're okay you're not you're not hot
[ __ ] as you think you are right so do
you have those types of people in your
life that you know when sometimes you're
going through to say dude listen behind
closed doors hey Brian let's relax this
liver King should I get it you're just
Brian bro kick it you know I when I play
dominoes which I'll whoop your ass so
you ain't that and I know your fears I
know you're insecurities like do you
have those types of people in your life
and if you do who are some of these guys
yeah I have a couple of guys like that
um my wife and I went through a 10-year
stint where we failed over and over and
over it was like we we stuck with
something far longer than we should have
and um and this is my advice to a lot of
entrepreneurs is get in there take
Massive Action you know fail fast fail
early because if you can do that in your
20s I mean what a gift that is
um and I'm like you know what I'm never
going back to that again and when my
wife retired you know she was like Hey
listen I'm gonna go I'm gonna be a
stay-at-home mom and now you're going to
figure all this other stuff out and I'm
like okay cool you know I'm gonna figure
this out and uh and I knew that I would
never go back to a brick and mortar that
was open Monday through Friday from
eight to whatever I'm like okay what's
open 24 7 365. how can I sell on 55
continents 55 continents 55. you're like
Elon Musk you go to other planets yeah
um so I would say that I got a couple of
guys around me that are way smarter than
me that do call me out of my [ __ ] and I
couldn't be more grateful for him you
know what one of them told me a long
time ago
um because we had gone into business
with somebody and
you know before going into business with
somebody like you don't have to ask
anybody anything you just do whatever
you want to do you're the owner right
um and then I went to business with
somebody and I no longer could really
just serve the mission that I had
and I said you know what I'm never doing
that again you know I'm never going to
have a business partner ever again and
then I got to know some guys that were
way better than me that I needed to have
around me so that you know I think
you've heard this before but it's like
you know if if you want to go fast go
alone if you want to go far go together
and you can go fast and far I believe if
you have a true a a tribe of True
Believers and so I got a couple of guys
around me that um are way better than me
you know that that do level me up that I
do look to them
um and but but here's the thing that
this this thing I've I've locked this
inside you know I've not shared this you
know with them and um they've had their
suspicions they've asked me in the past
and I've just kind of brushed to the
side and I've always just hey what are
you doing what are you taking look at
the way you look you know and and so
that wasn't fair to them but but I will
say that um there's no way that I would
have any of the success that I've had
financially without this team without
these guys that have been be better you
know we had president Bush at an event
two years ago whatever three years ago I
don't remember it was three years 2019
yeah and when I announced them people
were very upset why would you bring him
here do you understand what happened
with 9 11. I can't believe this you know
we're running an insurance agency half
our Democrats have our Republicans right
so it's not like and there's a
percentage that could give a [ __ ] about
politics but no matter who it is they
don't remember good things about what
media said about President Bush
and he got up and I'm interviewing him
and he starts talking about yeah one day
let me tell you I'm at the house
and I realized for five years my kids
are aging and all I'm doing is drinking
every night when I'm coming home I'm
like what are you doing I took all the
alcohol and I went to the bathroom and I
dropped and I put it on a flush the
toilet I was like I'm done and then from
there I cleared my life and actually you
know Governor president all this uh you
know at the end of it bro as crazy as it
sounds you know I don't know if history
is going to say this guy's one of the
greatest presidents of all time I don't
know if they're going to say that about
he's one of the greatest of all time but
I do think history is going to say
I like this guy you know I I he's not
going to be on the top 10 list but he's
going to be on the list of what a cool
guy you know he's never trashed Trump
he's never trashed Obama and Obama trash
Trump Obama trashed him Trump trashed
Obama Trump trashed him and he just sat
on the back he's like yeah just been
telling my family so he redeemed himself
and the world is now people who would
never have him on the show they're
having them on their show how can I like
this guy so I do think there's a
opportunity we all go through with this
part when you know we sometimes go
through and I just think it's important
to have the right people uh in your so
with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got him in white we got them in Black we
got them in red our black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he about three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks bright toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]